تقدم باتجاه بخمه الاوكرانيه يحققه الجيش
الروسي بعد اشهر من المعارك الدمويه حول
المدينه الاستراتيجيه ما يعزز التكهنات عن
قرب السيطره عليها
المسافه الفاصله بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه لا تتجاوز اربعه كيلومترات
سيطره القوات الروسيه على مدن وقرى مجاوره
قد تدفع بالجنود الاوكراني الى التراجع
الا انه سيكون تراجعا محدودا بحسب القاده
العسكريين في المنطقه لكن ما قد يعطل هذا
التطور وتمسك القوات المدافعه عن المدينه
بمواقعها في بناء التحصينات الدفاعيه فعلى
بعد مئات من الامتار يتم حفر خنادق على
سلسله من التلال المشافي والفرق الطبيه
ايضا تضع خططا طارئه للانتقال في اي لحظه
بالرغم من الضغط الناجم عن زياده الاص
بسبب القتال في ضخمه هيا اذا استماته حتى
الرمق الاخير فالوحدات الاوكرانيه تتدرب
بشكل خاص على الطريق ان صفر ثلاثه وهو
الطريق الاستراتيجي والاساسي في المنطقه
والذي يمدهم باسباب الاستمراريه من
الذخائر والمواد الاخرى هذا الشريان الذي
ابقى امل الحفاظ على ضخم تحيا لدى كييف هو
ذاته الذي فجر خلافات في المعسكر الروسي
فقوات فاجنر انتقدت عدم قطعه حتى الان
والقت باللوم على البيروقراطيه العسكريه
في جيش الروسي والتي تعرقل التقدم المامول
وربما لهذا بات التوقعات مؤسس فاجنر
بالسيطره على بخموت حتى مارس او ابريل وهو
تاريخ ابعد مما كان متوقعا عمر العربيه